[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight for many of us this has
been one of the saddest most painful
weeks in memory depressing doesn't even
begin to describe it we have watched as
mobs of violent cretans have burned our
cities defaced our monuments beaten old
women in the street shot police officers
and stolen everything in sight stealing
everything
how many innocent americans have these
people hurt how many have they murdered
we don't know that number
but it's the country itself that so many
of us worry about at this point
after we've watched what's happened over
the last week how do we put the society
back together can we we don't know that
either
if you're grieving for america tonight
you are not alone millions feel the same
way you do so many of our leaders by
contrast are not grieving they seem
exhilarated they feel nothing as our
nation descends into anarchy they see
chaos instead as an opportunity a chance
to solidify their control to increase
their market share to win elections they
have no interest in talking about the
details of what is actually happening
out there on our streets in fact they're
hiding those details they're demanding
that you forget what you saw
don't forget it remember all of it every
bit because it's proof of who they are
this is who they are
[Applause]
whoa
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh
that's what they're defending that's
what they're encouraging it has nothing
to do with civil rights it's violence
and the criminals you just saw on the
screen are not protesters the people
cheering them on from their tv studios
have no patience for real protests or
real protesters
just in april democrats in new jersey
arrested a woman for trying to plan a
rally a protest at the state capitol the
new york times said nothing when they
did that because they approved that's
how they really feel about any political
expression they can't control they crush
it
what they support is more power for
themselves and they're willing to use
gangs of thugs to get it here's one of
their protesters
nbc news wouldn't show you that video
ever neither would cnn under any
circumstances no justice no peace they
chant as the man tortures a dog
these are the worst people in america
and our leaders have let them do
whatever they want so of course they
want more their latest demand is that we
eliminate the police entirely no more
law enforcement in this country that
would mean more power for the mob they
could do anything it would mean never
ending terror for you and for your
family that's why they want it defund
the police
no sane person would dare to have said
something like that in public just a
week and a half ago now a member of
congress has endorsed the idea rashida
talib
so what would happen to our country if
we eliminated law enforcement
eric garcetti is the mayor of los
angeles the second biggest city in
america his city would devolve into a
murderous hellscape within hours if the
police left
but garcetti who is in charge of the
city won't push back against this idea
instead he kneeled in subservience
before the people demanding it
la mayor eric garcetti joined protesters
moments ago what did he have to say
yes he came out this morning jake and
he took the time to come out and come
out among the protesters he knelt while
he was out there saying it's showing his
solidarity for the movement for the
protesters here today and i can tell you
that today this daytime protest has been
very peaceful very calm lots of chanting
singing
he kneeled
our leaders are kneeling before the mob
the atavistic ritual of self-abasement
of defeat
suddenly many are performing this ritual
including police around the country
the mob wants victory but more than that
it wants the total humiliation of its
enemies
i work for black lives matter i'm sorry
that i scared you
but
since i work for that company my ceo has
told me to come out today
and to bring you on your knees because
you have white privilege so if they see
that a white person is getting on their
knees that shows solidarity for the
situation
the situation
and could you just please apologize for
you know for your white privilege
just apologize i am i'm trying to think
of the right words to say because that's
a that's a big thing to say it's it's
big
it's so it's large in this country
sorry
why do we kneel
we kneel because we've lost
we kneel before our victors because they
have won we put down our resistance we
beg for their mercy
but mobs rarely forgive we're on your
side we shout we're in solidarity spare
us
but they never
[Music]
we're do your side we're on your side
we're on your side
we're on your side as the rock comes
through the window you think the mob
cares no
what's happening to this country why are
americans surrendering to violent mobs
well because they've been told they have
to
everything we're now watching the
looting the arson the killing has a
purpose
the purpose we're told again and again
is to end racist police violence against
african americans we are told that that
is the single greatest scourge in this
country
for the past 400 years stemming from
slavery there has been a genocide of
black people in this country i'm sick
and tired of seeing black men and women
be killed and nothing be done about it
we had a black man in the office broke
they were still killing us bro stop
telling us
stop killing us stop killing us
stop killing us
it's chilling
and if you believe it and you're a
decent person you will be moved by it
because it's awful no american should
ever be mistreated by those in authority
much less killed the abuse of power is
always and everywhere a sin and it's
increasingly common here we should
always work to end it
in this case the death of a man at the
hands of police in minneapolis turned
out to be a metaphor for abuse of power
that death has led to demands that we
fire the nearly 700 000 police officers
who work in the united states and that
we free the million and a half criminals
who are now behind bars in america joe
biden told us recently quote just the
color of your skin puts your life at
risk senator cory booker of new jersey
strongly agreed with that quote we have
so many people in our country booker
said yesterday african-american men
mostly unarmed being murdered by police
officers and no way of holding them
accountable
so many people murdered by police
officers unarmed says cory booker you're
hearing a lot of people in authority
tell you that every day every hour one
group of pro athletes just announced
that quote it seems like every week a
new tragedy unfolds before our very eyes
where people are being killed by police
violence
each time we tweet we pray we mourn only
to repeat the cycle a few days later
end quote in the words of ben crump
who's the lawyer representing george
floyd's family in minneapolis what we're
witnessing here in america is quote
genocide
genocide
if you believed we were seeing genocide
then you might understand the riots now
in progress
there's nothing worse than genocide
but is it happening is any of this true
we should find out facts matter what
exactly are the numbers we found the
numbers and we're going to go through
them with you in some detail tonight
because it's worth it
since 2015 the washington post has
maintained a comprehensive database of
fatal police shootings in this country
last year the post logged a total of one
thousand and four killings of the 802
shootings in which the race of the
police officer and the suspect was noted
371 of those killed were white
236 were black the vast majority of
those killed were not in fact unarmed
the vast majority were armed and
african-american suspects were
significantly more likely to have a
deadly weapon than white suspects yet
more white suspects were killed
overall there were a total of precisely
10 cases in the united states last year
according to the washington post in
which unarmed african americans were
fatally shot by the police there were
nine men and one woman
now as we said a lot is at stake the
country is at stake so we want to take
the time now to go through these case by
case into the specifics
the first was a man called chanara feep
he was killed by a knoxville police
officer called dylan williams according
to williams phipp attacked him choked
him and then used a taser on him the
suspect on the police officer before the
officer shot him
five eyewitnesses corroborated the
officer's claim and the officer was not
charged
the second case concerns a man called
marcus mcveigh he was by any description
a career criminal from san angelo texas
he'd been convicted of aggravated
assault assault on a public servant and
organized criminal activity at the time
he was killed he was wanted on drug
dealing charges the texas state trooper
pulled him over mcveigh fled in his car
then he fled on foot into the woods
there he fought with a trooper and was
shot and killed the officer was not
charged in that case
marzus scott assaulted a shop employee
when a female police officer arrived and
ordered the suspect toward her car he
instead charged her and knocked her to
the ground at that point she shot and
killed him the entire incident was
caught on body camera the officer was
not charged
ryan twyman was being approached by two
la county deputies when he backed into
one of them with his vehicle the deputy
was caught in the car door he and his
partner opened fire the deputies were
not charged in that case melvin watkins
of east baton rouge louisiana was shot
by a deputy after he allegedly drove his
car toward the deputy at high speed the
deputy was not charged
isaiah lewis meanwhile wasn't just
unarmed he was completely naked williams
broke into a house and then attacked a
police officer the police tased williams
but he kept coming at them and attacking
the officer shot him they were not
charged
atiana johnson
jefferson was shot by a fort worth
deputy called aaron dean a neighbor had
called a non-emergency number after
seeing johnson's door open thinking
something might be wrong police arrived
johnson saw them approach from a window
and was holding a gun at the time
according to body camera footage the
officer shot johnson within seconds
jefferson that officer has been charged
with homicide
christopher whitfield was shot and
killed in a place called ethel louisiana
he had robbed a gas station deputy glenn
sims said his gun discharged
accidentally while grappling with
whitefields simms who is black himself
was not charged in that killing
kevin mason was shot by police during a
multi-hour standoff while mason turned
out not to have a gun mason claimed to
have a gun claimed to be armed and vowed
to kill police with it they believed him
mason had been in a shootout with police
years before
and finally the tenth case concerns
gregory griffin he was shot during a car
chase an officer called giovanni crespo
claimed he saw someone pointing a gun at
him later a gun was in fact found inside
the vehicle and yet officer crespo was
charged anyway with aggravated
manslaughter
those are the facts that is the entire
list from 2019 last year
10 deaths
in five deaths an officer was attacked
just before the shooting occurred that
is not disputed
one allegedly was an accident that
leaves a total of four deaths during a
pursuit or in a standoff so out of four
in two of those cases in fully half the
officer was criminally charged
is it possible that more of these
officers should have been charged of
course it's possible justice is not
always served that's for sure
but either way
this is a very small number in a country
of
325 million people this is not genocide
it's not even close to genocide it is
laughable to suggest it is
in fact the number of police killings is
dropping in 2015 during barack obama's
presidency 38 unarmed black americans
and 32 whites were slain by police
overall totals have fallen since then
and they have fallen far more
dramatically for african-american men
last year was the safest year for
unarmed suspects since the washington
post began tracking police shootings it
was the safest year for both white and
black suspects
at the same time this country remains a
dangerous place for police officers 48
of them were murdered in 2019 according
to fbi data that's more than the number
of unarmed suspects killed of all races
one final number for you because it
matters in 2018 7407
african americans were murdered in the
united states if 2019 continues on a
similar trajectory and we hope it
doesn't but if it does
that would mean that for every unarmed
african-american shot to death in the
united states by police
more than 700 were murdered by someone
else
usually by someone they know
again those are the facts they are not
in dispute
are african americans being hunted as
joy reid recklessly claimed on msnbc
recently or is something else happening
is our nation being ripped apart by a
total and complete lie a provable lie a
lie
used by cynical media manipulators and
unscrupulous politicians who understand
that racial strife race hatred is their
path to power even if it destroys the
country
you have the facts now and you can
decide what's really going on